hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the 20/20 chest bill
masters is the third match between
onigiri and Yanni paunchy and as we've
already seen a nipple won the first
match sorry giri won the first match the
never retaliated in the second match and
now we have the third one and third one
was also creative a crazy one because
like the previous two it consists of
four rapid games and two blades games
and if those six games end in a tie then
we go into our mageddon and in the first
game Nepal took the lead by B by winning
Game one however he blundered a piece in
Game two at which means that Giri
equalized Game three and four of the
rapids ended in draw and Game five which
is the first game of the blitz ended
also in a draw so this is game six that
we're showing and if this game also ends
in a draw then we go into our mageddon
Giri has the white pieces let's see what
happens and it's actually a very long
theoretical struggle Plus also boots
game so we will not be over analyzing
anything so Giri goes for d4 and the
knight to f6 by Neto we have Knight to
f3 g6 now not preparing to go for some
sort of an Indian defense g3 and the
Bishop to g7 now I will rush of the g2
and the d5 by Napo
we have castles and now neighbor also
castles we have C 4 by Giri end with c6
we transpose into the neo roomful
defense we have Queen to b3 and Queen to
b6 now it's very interesting
nipple plays this defense quite a lot he
had a plenty of times against some very
strong players and Yuri of course knows
this as both the giri and a PO are part
of the 2020 candidates tournament and of
course they have to prepare for each
other
so here ix the c3 continuing development
and rook to da we have a standard case
where white wants black to capture and
black ones white to capture so either
white or black i get the semi open a
file for there for the rooks so Bishop
to b2 neither player are interested in
capturing we have D captures and c4
Queen captures and Bishop to e6 now
going after the Queen Queen to a4 and
now Bishop to f5 so like we said this is
a very long theoretical struggle all of
these moves are well known and already
have been played and
who had this position against both
correct in thomashefsky and the Madeira
and never actually never lost a game in
this position and no moves here our look
after a one-week after d1 also known
movies Quinta a3 but the move get
replaced is a new move in the position
he actually plays rook after c1 which
means that he came prepared for this he
knows that nepo is well-versed in this
line and it is as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how NEPA deals with this rook F the c1
novelty we have Knight B to d7 he just
continues developing and now b4 by giri
now we have Knight to e4 going for some
traits opening up the diagonal for his
dark squared Bishop with III trying to
give up the dark square bishop here but
this dark square bishop is a bad bishop
in this position he's not really doing
all that much all of white sponsor on
dark squares so it doesn't really make
sense the eliminated the bishop so
instead a nipple goes for the night we
have the ship characters on c3 and now
Bishop to c4 yeah now the the knight
will have some problems reaching e5 or
if it does you can always just trade
bishops and napadas have the black
pieces he never lost the line again in
this line and he's feeling very
comfortable playing it and well just
just reaching Armageddon if needed so
Queen back to b3 getting the Queen to a
much more useful diagonal also maybe a4
a5 is an idea in the future so Bishop b5
kicking the Queen away but Queen to c2
and now Knight to f6 getting the Knights
to a much nicer square also Knight to e4
Bishop t4 is an option like if you make
a silly move like let's say rugby one
you can easily win by Bishop e4 so
Knights the e5 getting a knight to this
beautiful central outpost and offering a
trade of bishops which nipple goes for
we have captures captures and now Knight
the d5 just going after the dark square
Bishop here but also preparing to
capture on e5 which would mess up a
white pawn structure so here Aguirre
goes back for the moment Knight to d3
the knife can also find a very nice
outpost on c5 and Queen to c7 now we
have a four starting at the expansion on
the Queen side and now rook a to c8
at some point be 65 might might be a
possibility
so rook ate the b1 and now h5 my
neighbor he wants to play H for hand
bust open the position so here he goes
h3 and neppo continues with h4 he
sacrifices upon to open up at the white
king and the giri says okay fair enough
he plays g captures on h4 and now Bishop
to f6 just going after his pawn he
opened up a Giri sking and now he is
ready to attack problem is he doesn't
have anything to attack with the knight
doesn't really have a good way of
joining the attack and also the rooks
however King g7 followed by rook to e8
and there may be doubling rooks on the H
file does seem to be a possibility but
here Giri goes h5 and now it's a Giri
who's threatening to also open up this
this G file and when the knight moves
the Queen can also easily join the
action so therefore here goes for g5 he
doesn't want to open it up and now
Knight the c5 giri is now preparing to
bring the knight to the e4 to do some
damage over on the Kings side so King g7
preparing to bring the rook over to the
H file and maybe pick up the h5 pawn and
now Knights thief or now you could be
considering something like captures but
also if your ponies under attack you can
just easily defend it with Knight to the
g3 so you were in no rush this Bishop
isn't really going anywhere
so rook the h8 and now as the pawn is
under attack
Queen to e to defending it while getting
the Queen to where the action is rook to
h6 never prepares to double up with
rookie rook Sita h8 and now b5 by giri
saying that I would very much enjoy this
opens up since I do have a rook lined up
with your queen so rook Sita h8 nipple
continues going after the H phone and
now Knight the g3 so Gary always kept
his options here with the night the
night could have gone could have gone
anywhere but the knight now will come to
g3 so 93 defending the h5 pawn and with
the knight to defending the h5 point
which is on a light square and this
Knight has no clear way of helping out
with the attack the two rooks on the H
file are for the moment are rendered
useless so e six by
and now Bishop to d2 not allowing this
capture you might want to use the bishop
later on in the game and also if you're
interested in playing something like e 4
you don't wanna well you don't want to
play something like e 4 and running
tonight if four night if fork in this in
this occasion
so after East six Bishop back to be two
and now this will be a possibility as
the bishop covers DF four square and
Bishop to e7 now we have B characters
and c6 we have B captures and c6 and now
Giri goes for the probably the simplest
way of how to how to attack this well
weak pawn Quinta a6 and now there is no
good defense against just rook captures
and c6 the knight cannot go anywhere to
help out with the defense and you don't
have well you don't have any other
options you could try something like e 5
but that just seems a bit too ambitious
as well you you cannot release the the
hole that you have well a grip router on
the f5 square as Knight a5 check just
destroys everything
so after Queen a6 nepo says okay we have
to part with this point but we are going
to collect another one so Queen d8 and
here giri just captures that Queen
captures and c6 and now as the Bishop no
longer is blocking the knight on f6
Knight f6 now adding a triple attacker
to the h5 pawn however looked the b7
Giri goes after the a7 pawn and also
just put the rook on the 7th rank which
is always always very useful napal says
okay time to eliminate some points here
we have Knight characters on age five
and now rook to d7 getting the Queen
away but also just preparing d5 which
which is very important as d5 frees of
this diagonal you want to get your
Bishop to c3 and really really do some
damage here
so Queen to fate by nipple and now d5
opening up this this diagonal and there
is no no good way to keep it closed you
could try something like e 5 but it's
not not really something again night if
I just eliminated black you cannot you
can never do this so here we have knife
characters on g3 first Ellen
this threat of night of five forever but
now f capture some g3 we have rook
captures on h3 and now well there's not
much to be done I'm sure you all guys or
all of you see what's happening here
bishop the c3 check there's not not much
nipple can do here but it's still very
interesting for example if f6 then just
Queen captures on e6 and it seems like
you've defended but there's no defense
against just captures Bishop and that's
that's the game usually have one check
but after this King of three and there
are no more well there are no more no
more useful tricks after g4 King g4 and
that's it with the checks
so instead after Bishop the c3 check and
apple says ok I'm not touching the F
pawn King g6 but now Bishop captures on
h8 with Queen captures on h8 and now you
have this position you know you're
better however it's important to win not
to be better so feel free to pause the
video and find the winning move for
Geary while I give you Kappa a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the only move that wins and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's not real captures on e7 if you
capture this then you allow black to
form a drawing pattern rook H to check
in g1 and now Queen here will force you
to go for some sort of a repetition
because if not it's actually white was
getting checkmated you cannot block the
C 2 square is guarded twice so here you
would have to go into something like
characters characters characters with
the check and then be happy with a
repetition of moves and claiming the
draw so to those of you who found e D
captures an e6 our congratulations as
this is now the only move that wins now
the point is you are threatening this
discovery with check and then just all
of the lines and files open up in front
of the black King so here at nipple win
for rook to h2 check King to g1 and now
you see the point of this capture the
Queen now guards the h1 square that's
the point and now there is no rock - h1
and there is no way for an effort to
continue checking the white king so here
f5 was played by nappa there
there-there is no good try if you try
saving the best move the worship this
comes with with a discovery then you
just I mean it just falls apart
so here nepo tried f5 but this comes
with the price of a bishop
so rook captures an e7 and now rook to
h3 nipple now is well not threatening
much what queen characters and g3 you
kinda don't wanna don't wanna meet to
this so it's actually a force checkmate
in eight but it's not a very fancy
checkmate it starts with a check so I'm
not gonna ask you to pause the video and
find it however it is it is a lovely one
so we're just gonna show it so here of
course it starts with a nice check
Queenie and check King f6 rook f7 check
now the King hunt begins king e5 rook
the c5 with check queen bee 5 is also an
option we have worked the CFI with check
King to e4 and now Quintus e6 width
check with King captures on e3 and now
rook to e5 check and it was in this
position unmoved 48 that Janna for me
she resigned the game and with it the
match as there is nothing more to be
done here
after king d2 is played rugby 7 will be
checkmate as there is no nowhere for the
black king to hide so a really really
exciting stuff first giri wins then an
fo retaliates in the second match and
then giri wins the first one the third
one and as gary said in an interview
after the game it was destiny for him to
meet Magnus Carlsen in the finals but we
will have to see was it only his destiny
to meet him in the finals or was it also
his destiny to beat him in the finals so
we're gonna cover that tomorrow and in
the following days that the finals will
be played out and well I'm very much
looking forward to that so hopefully you
guys are as well yeah that's the game
end the coverage of the semi-finals I
would like to thank our block Roger
meteor chef mark Steinhardt Greg Robison
and Eddie sphere for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of the
chest bull masters twenty20 checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chest world
so thank you I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day
and a big big happy birthday to George
who turns 39 39 today see you guys soon